[Music]
good morning everyone thank you for
sticking around through the last day of
coalesced and today we're gonna be
talking about how you can take your
enterprise network and extend it out
into the cloud various ways of doing
that talking about reliability of those
mechanisms and talking about many use
cases on how you would do that so let's
start off so you've all seen this
picture or a picture much like it and
this is the Google backbone and the
network that you can connect to so one
of the things you would like to
emphasize here is that when you make
connections to your VPC in the cloud you
really are connecting to this
infrastructure so if you think about the
kind of connections we're going to be
talking about today which are
connections from your enterprise into
cloud it's also connections into this
backbone and it's a way to leverage that
backbone so there's a number of ways you
can connect to Google I'm going to talk
briefly about two methods that I'm not
going to talk in the rest of the deck
about one of them is direct peering and
the other one is carrier peering for
customers that need to connect to the
Google public infrastructure and what I
mean by the Google public infrastructure
that's our asn.1 five one six nine and
all of the public Google services that
search that's G Suites
that's YouTube and all the rest of it
the way you can connect to us is either
using direct peering or carrier peering
direct peering is where you meet us in
one of our peering locations and they're
roughly about a hundred all over the
world and you place a router there and
you peer with us using BGP you need to
meet our peering requirements and for
many customers that's very difficult so
we have a other product called carrier
peering and that's when you work with
one of our service provider partners and
there's a list on our website of them
and allow them to peer on your behalf
with us
a lot of customers use this some use it
for G suite connectivity others because
they want real low latency and fast
access to YouTube I'm kidding
the other methods for connecting our VPN
which we're going to talk about today
which is a way of using a
cryptographically secure method of
connecting over the Internet to GCP
networks your V PC and GCP and then
finally dedicated and partner
interconnect dedicated and partner
interconnect very much closely matched
the direct period peering solutions with
dedicated interconnect you meet us in
one of our pups and with partner
interconnect you mean meet with one of
our carriers which meets in one of our
pots I'll go into details about both of
those so which one do I use this is a
flow chart that kind of tries to help
you make those decisions by the way this
exact a similar version this flow chart
is available on the cloud google.com
slash interconnect site so for instance
if you're using G suite it sort of moves
you to direct peering or carrier peering
if you don't need a 10 gig pipe it tells
you maybe you want to use partner or
connect versus dedicated interconnect if
you know if you need if you can't meet
us at one of our pops what do you do you
do cloud VPN or the partner in a connect
solution and we'll get into all the
details about how this stuff works
promptly so the first thing we'd like to
talk about is how you use IPSec IPSec is
a low cost reasonable bandwidth solution
into GCP so roughly depending on how you
connect to us if you're connecting a
silver appearing link you can get up to
three gig per tunnel otherwise it's
about 1.5 gigs large packet per tunnel
and if we go through this diagram I want
to point out couple things first of all
if you notice there are two VPN tunnels
here and they're connecting you know
using BGP to a cloud router
you don't have to use BGP you can use
static address static routing but
recommend that use dynamic routing it's
less error-prone it's easier to manage
but one of the things is that you'd
notice those bgp sessions go to cloud
router the cloud router is not a
traditional router all it is is the BGP
control plane and using if you went to
an earlier talk that discussed Andromeda
and the underpinnings of our network
you'll understand that what the cloud
router is doing is taking routes and
programming our underlying Sdn fabric
and what it does is it programs routes
into the VMS and your V PC so if those
VMs know how to get off of your network
and what they have is that they have a
default route to the VPN gateway which
is managing encryption and forwarding
that traffic on to your on-premise
network what that means is that first of
all the cloud router can support up to
128 bgp sessions but it obviously can't
support 128 VPNs going through it
because you know packets per second
would kind of overwhelm it right so
rather than worrying about that we
program these routes directly into the
VMS and all you are then is limited by
the performance of the VPN gateway and
each individual tunnel which is about
1.5 gig but you can ecmp that and we
have customers that are doing 20 gig of
IPSec traffic between their V PC and
on-premise network so it's a cool very
scalable solution it offers an SLA and
it does have some drawbacks and then
it's going over the public Internet so
you're sort of you're beholding to the
latency x' and jitter and a public
internet connection so many customers
have used this to start out with but
eventually they move on to our other
interconnect solutions which are
dedicated interconnect and partner
interconnect so dedicated interconnect
as I said it's a 10 gig solution in
other words all the connections to
Google with dedicated interconnect are
supported at 10 gig per can
action we support flag groups of up to
eight so up to about 80 gig and then the
partner interconnect solution which will
give you sub write interfaces starting
at 50 megabits through many partners
which I'll cover in just a second so
let's talk a little bit about the
locations salute around the dedicated
interconnect solution first of all to
connect to us you meet need to meet us
in one of our colocation facilities and
I'll put a list of the colocation
facilities up in just a second you are
placing a peering router in that
facility and you're connecting to us
using cross connects to our peering edge
and I distinctly say a peering edge
because it's not a router it's just an
edge it's a 10 gig port you plug in and
using our espresso control plane allows
us to package up your packets and send
them on to your V PC by the way if you
don't know anything about espresso if
there's a great paper on espresso that
explains how we do peering on our edge
very interesting not just from an
academic standpoint but just on how you
build Sdn fabrics so did use dedicated
air connect router in one of our peering
locations and a cross connect to our
peering edge a little bit on
requirements so first of all it's 10
base L R so just a comment we've had
have customers that have come up with
other methods of connecting to us if
those don't work we also support Nellie
we require LACP the benefit of LACP is
as you want to grow that infrastructure
you can do it in a seamless way by
adding 10 gig connections and growing
that lag bundle as you need to so for
customers that have very large data rate
requirements or are thinking they're
going to have very large data rate
requirements it's really important to
for LACP to be their support of 802 1q
VLANs which is most if not all routers
support that EGP e
bgp with multi
is also required and finally ipv4
link-local addresses so all those are
the requirements that you need for a
dedicated interconnect solution as part
of the process you go into the cloud
console you'd get an Loa you hand it on
over to your data center provider
whoever that is and they would make that
connection there's a very hold your hand
approach on setting up these connections
so after you get the Loa there's
instructions in the email of what you do
next and take you step-by-step through
the process of setting up that
connection so we find it for the most
part to be very error non error-prone
leads you through the whole process and
we've had very very few escalations from
customers having a problem through that
process so we try to hold your hand if
you're using this method as far as
interconnect locations this is what we
have today across the globe so in North
America a couple locations in Canada and
a host of locations throughout the
United States one of the comments I will
make is that and I don't have an overlay
of our data center fabric here but when
you may be concerned about latency to VM
workloads and if you're concerned about
latency to VM workloads you want to be
extremely close to those VM workloads so
for instance in our Ashburn facility
that's the one that's marked as
Washington DC you're roughly about you
know around roughly around a millisecond
away from a VM same thing with our Los
Angeles facilities same thing with
Frankfurt London and a few others Tokyo
and a few others around the globe if
you're really concerned about latency
for instance if you're doing a lift and
shift workload where you have to leave
some of it in your data center so let's
say you have a very large db2 in-memory
database that you need to leave in your
data center you might want to think
about those facilities because you can
take that infrastructure and deploy it
in that facility and still have low
latency access to your VM workloads
so just something to think about when
you go around selecting a location to
connect to us one thing I will say about
this list of locations
it's a evolving list of locations so if
you don't see it up there it's probably
gonna be up there in about another
couple months or another half a year etc
so this is we're slowly rolling out
locations that support dedicated
interconnect over the next year so
there'll be a number of additional
locations there so now let's talk a
little bit about partner so the big
difference between dedicated and partner
is that you're not meeting us in one of
our colocation facilities we have a
number of partners that actually have
connections our colocation facilities
and can provide you a layer two
connection into that location so that
means that you're in your in your
facility and you're using one of those
partners to connect to us there are
different kinds of partners that can
connect to help you connect so let's
talk a little bit about them they're
Wave partners wave partners are
providing you a physical optical cable
from your location to a Google location
in that use case you're actually using
the dedicated product but you're using
it like if it was an extended quad the
optical fiber was like an extended cross
connect so you'd hand your Loa to your
wave partner and they would figure out
where they're meeting us or what you
tell them where you want to meet that
fiber and they would hand it over to
whoever's providing the patch panel in
that location so there are a number of
customers that use that because they'd
want the bandwidth and the connections
that dedicated offer offers but they
can't meet us in one of our coloration
facilities so they use a wave service
the benefit of this is that you don't
have to place equipment in the
colocation facility another type of
partner is what we call a layer to
partner there are either you know known
by e VPN or a pseudo wire partner and
what they're doing is all they provide
you is a physical connector
that then you can do a layer three VLAN
over that physical connection so there
are a number of partners and if you go
to our website we actually categorize
partners that do layer two or layer 3
connectivity but those partners are
giving you the ability to manage the
VLANs
on your equipment on premise and then
finally their layer 3 partners or layer
3 partner MPLS VPN is a typical way of
talking about them they're typically
doing BGP on your behalf to us and then
they're doing BGP to you as well so
they're managing how they can how you
can connect to us typically you're
connecting with an MPLS backbone and
you're telling them
can you please extend my MPLS backbone
to the cloud so for those of you that
have an MPLS partner this is a great way
to do it so if you were at a session
yesterday both AT&T with their product
called net bond and verizon with their
product SEI we're discussing how to do
this layer 3 type of connection so what
are the difference what are some of the
other differences of partner and
dedicated I think the biggest difference
between partner and dedicated is that
you can get sub right interfaces with
partner so for instance if you are a
retail established with many stores all
over the nation you don't need a 10 gig
connection per store you may want a sub
rate interface per store you probably
have an MPLS provider they're giving you
you know 100 megabit MPLS link to cloud
for each one of those stores so that's
something you can get with partner but
you can't get with a dedicated solution
some of the other big differences you
know because you're only paying for what
you need it can be less expensive it can
be less expensive with partner you don't
have to pay for the rack costs in a
colocation location you don't have to
think about the amortized costs of the
router that you're putting in that
location etc so sometimes partner can be
a more cost-effective solution and as
well with partner you can from start to
finish especially if you already have a
partner and connections to that partner
can be extremely fast order of minutes
whereas if you're using
unless you have the gear placed you have
the rack of bought you have all of those
contracts in place with the colocation
facility that can take a little bit
longer
typically dedicated takes order a week
versus partner can take order minutes
depending on the partner connection that
you have oh one other difference between
partner and dedicated is with dedicated
you own the 10 gig circuit it's yours
you can do anything you want with it you
land VLANs and multiple projects and
with a partner connection that 10 gig
circuit is shared amongst a number of
other companies we have provisions in
place so that that circuit is not
overloaded so we force our partners to
augment those circuits as they start
reaching capacity levels so let's talk a
little bit about the partners we have we
launched the partner solution about six
to seven weeks ago and we launched it
with this set of partners since then
we've added a number of additional
partners and we continue actually there
were a number of partners that would
have been on this list except they
didn't get the signature on the contract
in time so they were left off the list
because I had to do my slides at some
point right so this this list continues
to grow if you don't see your favorite
partner here come and talk to me we can
get them on the list and by the way if
you want to see a full list of the
partners there's a URL for that in
addition at that URL
I'll give you additional details about
the partner like how do you contact them
what services they offer things like
that and I will say one thing with this
suite of partners this also extends the
reach of the number of data centers that
we support so if you look at many of
these partners you think of and you go
to this URL you'll see that they only
meet us in certain locations but for
instance if you go to what's a good one
if you go to a partner like a mega port
they have connectivity in a large number
of facilities across
the globe so if you can't be in one of
our locations many of these partners can
help you be in one of those locations
because they have a very diverse set of
connectivity an example I just said mega
port another Equinix for instance has
their own backbone that connects all
their data centers together so if you're
in one of their data centers they can
connect you to cloud so many of these
partners give you that last smile that
land that extra data center connectivity
back into a cloud offering like GCPs so
let's talk a little bit about the
details of both partner and dedicated
interconnect I use a lot of the
dedicated interconnect diagrams here but
they also work for the partner
interconnect solution
so on your peering router whether it be
on premise or in one of our data sent
one of our colocation facilities you're
exposing a link local address to the
cloud router
we're exchanging BGP across that link
and we're extending your network into
your VP's cloud B PC that means that we
take routes from your network and we
program those routes on the VMS and we
take those VMs and expose those routes
to your data center as well so fully
meshed it just looks like you extended
your data center to another room but
what you've done is you've extended to
the cloud and in addition you've
extended to the globe as I'll go through
in just a second so we have a feature in
the cloud router called global routing
and what global routing does is it takes
your VPC subnets that are in other
regions and advertise them over a BGP
connection back onto your data center so
if you see this diagram we have two
connections one in one region one in
another region both of those connections
are advertising all the routes that you
have on your V PC the reason you might
want to do these in two regions is
because you may have a connection in
Tokyo
a connection in Chicago but what's
happening is you're getting all your
routes to all your VPC over those two
lengths so you may have a VM running on
a data center in London and you still
have access to it from your arm pram but
you don't have a connection in London
and the benefit is that you're going
over our backbone to get to those VMs
so as I said when I started this
presentation that large network you get
access to that large network with one
connection and this is a good example of
that
so in this use case we're connecting to
one region into one cloud router but
because of global routing we're
advertising the routes to other regions
over that one link so in this case let's
say you're connected in Chicago you
still have access to our data center and
Tokyo you have access to our data center
in London you have access to our data
center in Frankfurt or Mumbai or
wherever those regions are set up so
it's a very cost effective way of
extending the reach of your data center
network to a global footprint now I will
caution there are two charges when you
do this there's egress charges from your
local region so for instance you're
connected in Chicago there'll be a
[ __ ] charge from a local region to
Chicago out and if you want it to
connect to Tokyo you're gonna pay a
Tokyo to a local u.s. region egress
charges as well but again it's cheaper
than stringing a long-long connection to
a data center halfway around the world
so let's talk about how you connect
multiple projects in the dedicated use
case you'd have multiple VLANs over that
same 10 gig connection in the partner
use case you just have multiple VLANs
you don't care how they route or who
they route over but what you're doing
now is with multiple projects you have
complete separation between those two
projects you have network assets in
those two projects they don't know they
don't know one from one other even if
you're using the dedicated single tank
connection they can have overlapping
address space they can do all that kind
of stuff so this is one way of
connecting multiple projects it is not
the recommended way that some people
need to do it this way the recommended
way is to use something called shared
VPC how many of you know what shared VPC
is we're doing our job what shared VPC
allows you to do is think of each
individual project the way you would
think about resources that you have in
your data center so when you have a
developer come to you and say I need VM
resources I need network access I have
this special project I'm working about
on you don't care what the project is
but you need to give them network access
that's what shared VPC is doing unless
you say I control the network resources
I control the firewall rules and I give
you access based on what your needs are
do you need you know access back to your
data center you know database probably
not so you fire all that stuff off the
shared DPC allows you to control who
gets access to the network
what firewall rules are placed on those
individual projects so this is a way of
using your network ax ax assets in the
most efficient way possible so I have
customers come to me and say I need a
hundred VLANs well why do you need a
hundred VLANs well I have a hundred
projects I need to connect back to my
data center what you really think it
would if you think about that what they
really want to do is they want to use
shared VPC because they don't need a
hundred millions they want to give
networking to 100 projects and this is
an efficient way actually I got the
scaling numbers wrong but this is an
efficient way of giving access to a
number of projects using one VLAN
resource so you can put in a high
capacity VLAN and have good access to a
number of projects and control the way
they access your data center
and by the way there was a great talk on
this that you should listen to because
it's already happened so be available in
YouTube in a week or so so let's talk
about connecting to multiple clouds
because I don't care who you are you
most likely have some resources that are
running in another cloud and how do you
do that well there are a couple methods
of doing that what I'm showing here is
showing how you would use a router that
you have in a colocation facility or
on-premise and you take two legs stick
one and one cloud service provider and
stick the other one in GCP you'd get
route information from both of those and
now you have a connection between those
resources into cloud infrastructures the
one thing you have to remember is you
are you could have an issue with
overlapping IP so you need to be careful
at in that you can't have overlapping
IPs without having an at device
on-premise
now you say wow that's a real pain I
have to go stick a router in some point
to present someplace and connect this
and manage all that that's a real
over-the-top amount of effort there are
companies and I'll mention mega port
here because there's their product is
actually in production right now and
there's another large infrastructure
provider that is actually doing
something very similar what they've done
is they've virtualized the routing
function in those pops and they give you
api's or user interface that allow you
to point and click and connect to CS
piece together so a very easy to use
very cloud-like approach to connecting
to cloud service providers together so
the mega port solution is called the
mega ports cloud router it's on their
website you can trial it it has a pretty
nice user interface to walk through they
have a booth on site too as well the
other and I can't speak for the other
company that's doing this because I've
not authorized to but I'm sure you'll
see press when they're they make their
solution available
so that's how you'd connect to cloud
service providers together there's
actually another method of doing this as
well because one thing you can do is
just connect them using an IPSec
connection so the cloud VPN solution
there are a number of guides that help
you connect to common cloud service
provider infrastructure and you can make
an IPSec connection you can have
multiple links you can do ecmp over
those multiple links and get pretty
reasonable connectivity between GCP and
other cloud service provider Google as a
whole has very good I would say rich
connectivity pairing between our CSP
competitors so you can be assured that
those links are going over adequate
connectivity so let's talk a little bit
about high availability because your
connections from your data center to
cloud really need to have some level of
reliability when you can connect so to
do a we offer two SL ade levels with the
dedicated and partner interconnect
solutions again it doesn't matter which
one you're using you have to do more or
less exactly the same thing you have to
meet us in one Metro with two links to
get a three nines of availability what I
mean by a metro is if you remember that
that map with all the points of presence
a metro is one of those points of
presence so you need to meet us in one
of those points of presence with two
connections if you're using dedicated
that means you have to ten gig links if
you're using a partner solution that
means you have to VLANs
connected in that Metro that will give
you a three nines of SLA we also
recommend that you use graceful restart
on the cloud router and I'll go into
some details of that in just a bit to
get to four nines of availability you
need to meet us in two metros with two
connections in each one of those metros
so let's say you're meeting us in
Chicago you also need to meet us in
Dallas or Los Angeles or somewhere else
to get the four nines of availability
and again I stress that this is 2 metros
because our SLA s our Metro bound and
they're not for connections anywhere you
want so this is a way of getting a four
nines of SLA into the Google
infrastructure in addition you need with
the four nines of SLA you need to
implement global routing on the cloud
router so that I can advertise all the
routes over those links so if one link
fails I can use the other link to
connect to GCP so we talked about IPSec
as being a method of connecting back in
to the Google infrastructure as a way to
start out you know you're not sure you
want to do do this or you don't know
what the volume of connectivity is or
you're just in a a proof of concept so
you can start with an IPSec connection
to connect to us the default you know ID
by the way I recommend using dynamic
routing this particular use case is all
going to be using dynamic routing and in
this case you're advertising all your
BGP routes using a default on med of a
hundred but now you want to move over to
a dedicated or a partner interconnect so
you've set up two VLANs or two dedicated
10-gig links with VLANs over them and
you've set a default med priority of a
thousand what that means is that your
IPSec connection is the preferred path
to and from your data center and the
secondary path is that dedicated
interconnect and you can go through the
CLI or you can use the GUI and you can
change the med values and traffic
immediately swings over to the preferred
method that you've chosen so in this use
case you've moved all your traffic over
the VPN and you've moved it on to the
new dedicated interconnect these
one of the benefits here is also you can
still maintain that IPSec connectivity
so if you have a problem with the
dedicated interconnect you'll all swing
back to your VPNs as well so a nice very
simple way of doing both the transition
and a failover mechanism to the VPN
tunnels so we talked a little bit about
graceful restart as a way to minimize
downtime cloud router is a software
component we update it all the time like
once a week we're doing some change to
it updating that software and you will
have an issue because your bgp session
goes down bgp session goes down you lose
connectivity withdraw routes do all that
kind of stuff so graceful restart is a
way of not withdrawing routes when you
have a BGP session down and it gives you
the ability to say wait for a little bit
of time before you withdraw routes that
bgp session might be coming back up and
I want to be assured that you know I
still have connectivity our
recommendation is to and by the way
there's a lot of documentation on this
on our website as well as there the
sample CL is for both juniper and cisco
gear on how you set all of this up to
take advantage of our recommended
configuration and the recommendation is
to just don't turn on graceful restart
but do not use any of the modifiers for
grace or restart and what that will do
is it will give you a connection that
has about 61 seconds of failover time
that means from if your bgp session went
down because of an actual let's say a
physical cut and cables or something
like that it'll take about 61 seconds
for that BGP track that traffic to fail
over to the secondary link we're going
to improve the timing on this through
implementing some other methods that you
find in common off-the-shelf routers and
those who you know things like PFD and
will improve this time this
fail overtime overtime so but this today
is the default recommended configuration
and this will give you a 61 second
failover time we also talked a lot about
global routing and I want to go a little
bit under the covers on how global
routing works and what you get out of
global routing so when you set up global
routing that means all the subnets are
advertised over your BGP session if you
have multiple connections to GCP you
want to make sure that you're using the
optimal path so for instance if you have
a connection in Tokyo and in one in
Chicago you don't want your data center
in Tokyo to go over your backbone and
come into Chicago so what we do is on
the advertisement we modify the meds of
the remote subnets by adding the RTT
value of those remote subnets so your
subnets in Tokyo will have a very look
low med value in Tokyo and they'll very
have a very high med value in Chicago so
traffic from Tokyo will prefer your
Tokyo connections and traffic from
Chicago will prefer the Chicago
connection the one comment I will make
is that you should make sure that the
default med values are far enough apart
so you don't run into an issue for
instance if you were to default of a
hundred and let's say you're doing
Chicago in New York you may have some
interesting if you want to prefer your
Chicago connection all the time add a
thousand to the default med value that
you're advertising out of New York so
that you don't get into an issue where
the round-trip time is longer than the
default net value that you're
advertising so that'll that'll always
prefer one connection over the other if
you have a very large amount of value to
the default net value and all of these
things are available in the cloud router
CLI as well as in the GUI to be able to
set all that up
monitoring so now you have all this
great infrastructure set up than you've
everything is working great how do you
monitor this infrastructure there are
two distinct ways of monitoring this
infrastructure one of them is you can go
into the cloud console and we will give
you things like link utilization drop
data etc and those are time series
values so you can select whether you
want to see the last hour or the last
day or last week etc so a pretty nice
rich user interface around all the
monitoring data and you can get that
right out of the cloud console in the
section around the object you're trying
to monitor so you can go into the
interconnect and monitor that
interconnect you can with partner you
can go to the VLAN and monitor that VLAN
in addition to that we also support
stack driver monitoring so for instance
if you want to put alerts on if you're
using dedicated interconnect and you
want to put alerts on the the value the
DB value associated with the connection
you know how what's the light levels on
a particular connection and if they drop
below a certain level you want to be
alerted you can do all of that in stack
driver if you want to do an alert that
says my link utilization is up over 75%
you can do that into stack driver and
get those alerts so that you know what's
going on
while we're talking about alerts let me
mention one other thing we take down
infrastructure from time to time mainly
for maintenance you know we're putting a
new line card we're readjusting some
ports stuff like that all of that
information is also available in the
cloud console you can get alerts on when
we do maintenance outages so you're
aware your BGP sessions go down it's not
an issue you know that that's a
maintenance window you've done an outage
we try to notify you within our
reasonable amount of time so that if you
want to for instance swing your traffic
away from one link to another because of
that maintenance event you can do that
so all of that is available in the
console all of this is documented as
well so I do recommend reading the
documentation I'm always surprised at
how many customers always do a Google
search before they actually go read the
documentation and the Google search just
takes them back to the documentation so
a good way to figure out how these
products work there's not a lot of
documentation there's enough it's not a
long read take it take advantage of the
the time and effort our doc people go
into putting out a really stellar amount
of documentation that helps you
understand how all this stuff works so
finally let's talk a little bit about
how much all of this stuff costs
so VPN we charge five cents per tunnel
hour that works out I believe $32 a
month for a VPN tunnel with dedicated
interconnect it's $1,700 for a 10 gig
circuit per month and then for every
VLAN that you put on that 10 gig circuit
it's a Sarge of $72 so 4 are redundant
if you're thinking about redundancy
three 9s would mean two connections so
$3,400 a month and then of course with a
four nine server redundancy you're
doubling that again 478 that's six to
eight hundred dollars a month the other
on the partner interconnect it's a
sliding scale it starts about $39 a
month for an it 50 megabit attachment
and goes all the way up to $1700 for a
10 gig attachment our pairing solutions
are free both carrier our direct peering
solutions free our carriers peering
solution is free of course you may have
to be paying some money to ever the
carrier is that's helping you appear but
we have a settlement free peering
solution of course you do pay egress
costs on those links and those aggress
costs on our internet egress cost rate
so speaking of egress on an on VPN on
VPN it's just like an internet
connection so depending on how you're
connecting to us and where you're
connecting to us that's runs from about
8 cents a gig all the way to 23 cents a
gig and the higher end of the scale is
for places like you know Australia and
South America where costs us a lot more
to provide transit of those locations
for dedicated and partner interconnect
in North America we charge two cents per
gig if you're interested in other
locales please go to the website and all
that pricing is available there as well
for carrier and direct peering we do
give a discount on our standard internet
rate of egress and in North America
that's five cents per gig for both
carrier and dedicated and direct peering
so we gave a lot of sessions at this
conference and this is the list of all
the sessions that are here the reason
I'm putting this up is all these
sessions will be available on youtube so
if you miss something that's a crucial
interest to you like I think there's
actually one happening exactly the same
time so if you were worrying about
enterprise-ready networking for gke
which is happening at exactly the same
time slot go to youtube and you'll be
able to get that presentation online and
finally two final things I I don't know
if you guys have seen this we have a
wonderful poster that's a it's an online
giveaway in other words you go to this
site and either you can download it
yourself or you can have it mailed to
you but this is a poster that shows our
network all our pop locations all our
data center locations all our undersea
cables all our terrestrial cabling etc
all in one beautiful picture so it's
kind of a cool you know put up on your
wall and people will ask you what's the
map of the world all about finally in
closing I like if you could please give
feedback on this session you'll find
feedback in the next 18 application
under let's see if I get this right
under notifications and they'll have all
the sessions that you've attended and
you can get feedback there it's kind of
hard to find but we really appreciate
any feedback you can give
[Music]